North Korea has built up a reputation for
being one of the strictest and most rigid
countries in the world.
From their tight control on emigration to
their unforgiving labor camps, it’s no question
that North Korea is not messing around.
One of the most notable aspects of North Korea
has been their missile and rocket development
effort.
The media has been pointing to this as being
a major threat for decades now, and leaders
around the world have consistently tried to
get North Korea to denuclearize.
As the world powers move into space and create
things like the US Space Force, however, will
North Korea be able to keep up or is nuclear
technology their last hoorah?
Well, here’s everything we know about North
Korea’s elusive space agency.
Taking a look back, North Korea didn’t establish
a space program for quite some time after
World War 2.
It wasn’t until the 1980s that North Korea
created the Korean Committee of Space Technology
or the KCST.
The KCST was originally responsible for everything
related to the country's space effort from
designing new satellites to developing launch
technology.
The organization's first step though was building
a launch facility.
In the early 1980s, the KCST built the Tonghae
Satellite launching ground in the North Hamgyong
Province.
The construction effort wasn’t super organized
though.
The North Koreans built the launch facility
on and off throughout the 1980s and 1990s.
By 1985, they completed construction of their
launch pad, but aside from that, they didn’t
have much to show after years of construction.
They simply had a rudimentary command bunker,
a radar facility, and a few storage and support
buildings.
The initial goal was to just reverse engineer
the Soviet Union’s Scud rocket and produce
their own copies though.
So, the rudimentary infrastructure was enough
for the time being.
Throughout the 1990s, however, the North Koreans
would significantly expand this facility.
Reports suggest that the site grew from just
2 kilometers in length to 9 kilometers in
length.
The new additions included a missile assembly
facility, a fuel storage facility, a guidance
and range control centre, and tracking facilities.
As the Tonghae Satellite Launching ground
was finished up, the North Koreans shifted
their effort to building a new launching site
called the Sohae Satellite Launching Station.
Construction began in the early 1990s, but
like the Tonghae site, construction would
stretch out for quite some time.
It wasn’t until 2011 that the site was completed.
The North Koreans did get a lot more work
done though as the base ended up being 6 square
kilometers which is 5 times larger than the
Tonghae site.
Aside from being much larger, the Sohae site
was also far more advanced and included elements
such as a static rocket motor test stand and
a much more substantial mission control center
instead of the command bunker they used to
use.
In terms of actual missions and space programs,
the North Koreans have only had three substantial
programs thus far with the first one being
Taepodong.
Taepodong was the final result of trying to
replicate the Soviet’s Scud rocket.
The Scud rocket was a series of tactical ballistic
missiles, so initially, there were fears that
North Korea could use Taepodong as a surface
to surface missile.
But, the US Defense Intelligence Agency would
later suggest that Taepodong was simply a
test bed for developing more advanced multi-stage
missile technology.
Anyway, in August of 1998, North Korea launched
Taepodong-1.
North Korean media reported that Taepodong-1
reached orbit within 5 minutes after launch
and that they had successfully launched their
first satellite.
But western scientists disagree with this
report.
According to their observations, Taepodong-1
was launched and it did reach an altitude
of 200 kilometers.
However, they suspect that the third stage
failed to ignite as the satellite never actually
reached orbit.
Based on where the third stage landed, scientists
estimate that Taepodong could reach up to
5900 kilometers though if the mission was
successful.
And that brings us into their second attempt
with Taepodong.
North Korea launched Taepodong 2 in July of
2006, nearly 8 years after Taepodong 1.
Unfortunately, there is absolutely no footage
or images relating to this mission, but the
US Department of Defense did confirm that
the launch did in fact take place.
There’s not too much to discuss though as
the missile apparently failed just 40 seconds
after launch.
Though it doesn’t seem like the reliability
of the missile was improved, observers speculate
that the missile was much more powerful.
It’s estimated that each stage of the missile
could have a burn time of about 100 seconds
which translates to a total burn time of 5
to 6 minutes.
With a bit of tweaks, this could allow for
up to 9000 kilometers of range with a payload
capacity of up to 500 kilograms.
Unfortunately for North Korea though, this
would never materialize, and they would move
onto a new series of rockets called Unha.
Unha, which means galaxy, was basically a
frankenstein rocket that incorporated elements
from a few different rockets.
The first stage of Unha uses four Nodong motors
which are simply enlarged versions of Scud
motors.
Originally, the second stage was thought to
be based on the Soviet SS-N-6 missile.
But, now the general consensus is that the
second stage is also based on the Scud rocket.
As for the third and fourth stage, these seem
to be identical to the Iranian Safir rocket’s
second stage.
So, once again, it doesn’t seem like North
Korea added much themselves when designing
the Unha rocket as it's just a combination
of Scud and Safir.
Despite this, the Unha rocket would stir up
quite a bit of controversy.
You see, according to the United Nations Security
Council Resolution of 1718, North Korea was
prohibited from testing ballistic missiles.
And as you might’ve guessed Unha was a ballistic
missile.
The US, South Korea, and Japan would all raise
red flags that this launch would violate the
agreement.
Even Russia urged North Korea to cancel the
planned launch.
Nonetheless, North Korea would go ahead and
launch Unha-2 on April 5, 2009 according to
South Korea.
The US Northern Command identified that the
first stage of the rocket fell into the Sea
of Japan and the other stages fell into the
Pacific Ocean.
The missile traveled a rather impressive 3850
kilometers from the launch site, but the US
suggests that the third stage didn’t actually
separate and that the rocket failed to insert
anything into orbit.
North Korea, however, still claims that the
rocket was fully successful and that it put
a satellite into orbit.
Moving onto their second launch of Unha, we
have Unha-3 which took place in April of 2012.
North Korea was actually super confident about
this launch and they even invited observers
from eight different countries to come witness
the launch.
But unfortunately for North Korea, the launch
was a failure.
We don’t really have any details as to what
exactly happened, but it does seem like North
Korea was indeed super close to successfully
launching a satellite.
Just 8 months later in December of 2012, another
Unha-3 rocket was launched.
And this rocket would successfully launch
a satellite into Sun Synchronous orbit.
Though this was a massive milestone for the
North Koreans, it wasn’t all good news.
A few days after the launch, Harvard astronomer
John McDowell suggested that though the satellite
had reached orbit, it was uncontrollably tumbling
in orbit and the satellite had yet to transmit
anything.
Following the partially successful mission,
the North Koreans decided that it was time
to rebrand themselves.
In April of 2013, they created a new space
agency called the National Aerospace Development
Administration or NADA.
I don’t think North Korea realized that
NADA means nothing in Spanish, but this coincidence
has become a running joke within the media.
Anyway, moving onto the final and most recent
launch, we have another Unha-3 launch.
This final launch took place in February of
2016, and it seems to be North Korea’s first
fully successful launch.
The director of the scientific research department
of NADA confirmed that they had received photographs
from the satellite, and thus far, there has
been no evidence suggesting otherwise.
So, North Korea does have the capability to
launch small satellites into orbit.
As for the satellites themselves, all of the
North Korean satellites are part of the Kwangmyŏngsŏng
program.
China helped North korea develop the first
Kwangmyŏngsŏng satellite, and it seems like
North Korea has simply been improving the
Chinese design ever since.
There have been a total of four satellites
within this program thus far, and two of them
have made it to orbit with one of them tumbling
around.
These satellites are simply communication/earth
observation satellites, so they’re thought
to be completely benign.
And that’s basically everything we publicly
know about North Korea’s space agency.
But that still leaves the question, how dangerous
is North Korea’s Space agency?
Well, the Center for Strategic and International
Studies or CSIS at Georgetown University answered
just that.
According to the CSIS, there are four major
threats that could come from North Korea’s
rocket/missile program with the first being
kinetic physical counterspace weapons and
more specifically Kinetic ASATs.
ASAT stands for Anti-satellite weapon, and
as the name suggests, these weapons are used
to strategically destroy the satellites of
other countries.
Thus far, North Korea has not tested nor announced
the development of any Kinetic ASAT technology.
Moreover, even if they wanted to, the CSIS
suggests that North Korea still has several
technological hurdles to cross to develop
an ASAT, so these aren’t a threat.
Moving onto the second category, we have Non-Kinetic
Physical Counterspace Weapons.
One example of such a weapon is launching
a nuclear warhead into space and detonating
it.
Some sources suggest that North Korea is actually
working on developing such a device.
However, there have been no known tests thus
far, and the CSIS doubts that North Korea
has enough technology to create such a weapon
without help from China or Russia.
In 2013, a Chinese military commentator actually
suggested that North Korea does possess this
weapon.
If this is true, then North Korea likely got
it from China or Russia.
But given that North Korea can’t yet produce
it themselves, it’s nothing to be worried
about.
Moving on, we have electronic counterspace
weapons.
This includes technology that can jam GPS
and communication signals from satellites.
North Korea does actually possess this technology,
and they have been using the jamming technology
against South Korean satellites since August
of 2010.
This actually violates the 1953 Armistice
agreement, but no action has been taken.
After all, while jamming signals can be a
nuisance, it’s not necessarily dangerous.
So, the international community has more or
less just decided to let North Korea have
a blast jamming satellite signals.
And finally, the last major space threat from
North Korea is Cyber Counterspace weapons.
This includes hacking satellites and space
systems from other countries to extract information
or inject corrupt information.
The North Korea cyber division is actually
quite strong especially after Kim Jong Un
took over.
However, western countries seem to still have
the edge when it comes to cyber warfare.
So in conclusion, NADA is not that dangerous
at this point in time.
They’re able to jam signals and might be
able to hack a few satellites.
But, in terms of physical weapons, it looks
like we're good to go.
And that’s everything we know about North
Korea’s space agency today.
Do you guys think North Korea is a serious
threat?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you thought this video
explained NADA well.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.